[Musique]
tiens nicolas et michel meyer ont pu ont
pu se rendre assez rapidement ce matin
sur sur les lieux même de l'explosion
regardez le reportage on la reconnaît à
peine et pourtant il s'agit bien de la
rocade de toulouse
il est 10h30 soit 3 à 4 minutes après
l'explosion
le complexe chimique à l'origine de
l'accident se trouve à droite à environ
150 mètres il n'en reste rien sur la
rocade des automobilistes air hagard et
hébétée il commence à réaliser ce qui
vient de leur arriver
on a eu une grande vous regardez sur la
tapoa voiture comme une bombe qui a
explosé là bas c'est la bac
voilà ma fille eton visuel essayer de
garder la maîtrise du jeu depuis deux
semaines c'est une accident si
incroyable du coup comme ça on roule
depuis son explosion
c'est tout on entendu une grosse
explosion sur place les automobilistes
s'entraîne et commence à organiser les
premiers secours en tentant de nous
approcher
nous passons d'abord devant la société
nationale des poudres et explosifs il y
a des blessés mais l'explosion n'est pas
venue de là le spectacle de dévastation
nous attend un peu plus loin sur le site
dit de la grande paroisse est un
complexe pétrochimique déjà ancien et
dont la présence aux portes de la ville
est dénoncée depuis longtemps
on y fabrique des engrais à partir
d'ammoniac d'habitude
deux à trois cents personnes travaillent
à cet endroit dont il ne reste
absolument rien des bâtiments de béton
ou voler en éclats des voitures et
wagons et des camions ont été déformés
par le souffle de l'explosion
dans toulouse même il ne reste guère de
vitrage dans un rayon estimé entre 3 des
5 km le bilan de cette catastrophe sera
très lourd
nous avons reçu de nouvelles images je
ne les ai pas encore vus nous allons les
découvrir ensemble je vous rappelle
quand même les principales consignes de
sécurité et elles sont nombreuses les
services de secours demande à la
population toulousaine et à la banlieue
de rester chez elles dans un endroit
confiné de libérer bien évidemment les
axes de circulation pour permettre aux
services de secours de la vie mais aussi
des départements voisins de venir faire
leur travail sur les lieux de la
catastrophe
libéré aussi si possible les lignes
téléphoniques parce que le réseau est
saturé c'est très difficile pour les
services de ce furent deux de faire leur
travail
il faut savoir aussi qu'il est qu'il est
bien d'éviter de consommer l'eau potable
non pas parce qu'il ya un danger mais
parce qu'il ya une usine qui alimente
les conduites qui aurait été touché et
c'est tout simplement pour éviter une
pénurie
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter de
nouveaux témoignages qui ont été repris
ce matin par nicole knowles excusez moi
mais justement des salles à vous êtes
blessé je parle pas j'étais au travail
et vous monsieur excusez-moi j'ai lavé
moi une vraie demande dur commence à
s'écrouler lequel on est sortis plus
vite mais c'est bon régime angle
première fois que je que j'ai dit c'est
vrai on était dans un atelier et ça a
explosé
on n'a rien vu non non on pense que
c'est plus vers la grande tour verts qui
avaient déplu à lier allait tomber et la
brique koala a ici c'est le désamour
nitrates
[Musique]
et
est ce que tu sais les oled famille et
ont essayé après d'aller voir allure et
pascal sûrs et on sait pas du tout ce
qui se passe il est le directeur
je suis le directeur adjoint on a eu une
explosion ont surtout se retrouvait dans
l'état où on est là je ne peux pas vous
en dire plus pour l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les blessés et j'ai fait
évacué à l'hôpital marchant qui est à
côté
la plupart des gens valides parce que
nous avons potentiellement un problème
de gaz de fuite de gaz dans l'usiné il
ya beaucoup de décès
pour l'instant je pense qu'il y ait au
moins une dizaine de blessés il ya un
acte sont dans un état très grave
oui je pense mais pour l'instant je
pourrais vous donner de diagnostic un
peu première priorité c'est isoler les
suites potentielles de gaz évacuer les
blessés
enfin on essaiera de comprendre d'où ça
vient le site de cuisine a été lui
entièrement dévastés stupéfiants des
images qui rappellent celles d'un
bombardement
plusieurs bâtiments proches ont été
partiellement ou totalement détruits
valérie ermite
c'était un complexe industriel
il n'en reste plus rien 10h20 ce matin
une explosion gigantesque dévastent
l'usiné pétrochimique à z
une usine qui produit des engrais à la
périphérie de toulouse
l'explosion aurait eu lieu dans l'un des
ateliers d'azf une tour de stockage de
nitrate à sa place désormais un cratère
de près de 50 mètres de diamètre
on a eu une explosion on sait tous qu'on
pouvait dans l'état où on est là je ne
peux pas vous en dire plus pour
l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les pc évacué les employés du
site
près de 350 personnes se trouvaient dans
l'usiné et des centaines d'autres dans
les bâtiments alentour souffler eux
aussi par la violence de l'explosion
j'étais juste à côté jusqu'à fin 2005 a
explosé et je me tire aujourd'hui j'ai
vite et pas monter dans le ciel est déjà
grave souffre et voilà il y avait tout
de retourner tout un grand massacre
des blessés partout moi j'ai vu juste à
côté de l'usiné où un travail et les
jambes et la tête ouverte elimane kane
combien de morts combien de blessés sous
ces bâtiments effondrés ces voitures des
trucs
les clients des magasins darty tout
proche de l' usine serait aussi décédée
sur la rocade de toulouse qui jouxte le
site
la vie c'est comme arrêter des dizaines
de voitures sont endommagés des dizaines
de passagers sont blessés
après avoir comme une bombe qui a
explosé là bas c'est la base pour la
bastille et toutes ont une vision
incroyable de nous concentrons roulé
puis sur l'explosion mais c'est tout on
entendu une grosse explosion
l'origine de l'explosion n'est toujours
pas déterminée le bilan est encore
incertain mais d'ores et déjà cette
catastrophe est la plus meurtrière
qu'ait connu l'industrie chimique en
france
cette explosion est la plus meurtrière
en france dans une usine pétrochimique
depuis 15 ans depuis plusieurs années de
nombreux habitants des quartiers situés
à proximité du site avait alerté les
autorités sur les risques d'accident le
reportage de pierre nicolas et dix
années de pertes
un blessé passe son chemin encore hébété
des heures après l'explosion les forces
de l'ordre tentent par tous d'organiser
la circulation des commerçants
s'affairent sur leur devanture éventrée
après la surprise on veut faire bonne
figure mais ce soir c'est la colère
qu'on sent poindre et parfois le
sentiment d'abandon il confié ni
secouriste ni psychanalyse père ya des
gamins partout et vous hier par souci
menace de s'effondrer vous aurez voir
les balcons et saft et à personne et je
trouve ça lamentable dans toute la zone
a touché par la déflagration commerçants
et habitants sont convaincus que ce
drame aurait pu être évité certain qu'on
connaissait les risques
robin admissible que la ville elle-même
ce qui se passe dedans et les laisse
continuer ne ferme pas lusine le temps
que les normes sont mis en place il ya
très très longtemps on avait fait des
pétitions entre voisins parce qu'on le
sentait tout sur l'ammoniac on avait
fait monter la cheminée de 2,10 m mais
l'ammoniac était toujours dans certains
pavillons outre les vitres brisées les
toits se sont effondrés
la mère de cette habitante était dans
cette chambre deux minutes avant que le
plafond ne tombe
cette fois on a évité le pire il faut
maintenant s'occuper de trouver des
bâches se reloger d'urgence et éviter
les cambriolages
toute la nuit des gardiens surveilleront
des rez-de-chaussée ouvert à tous les
vents et bien sûr le plan rouge a été
aussitôt mise en place dans tous les
hôpitaux et dans toutes les cliniques de
la région mais leurs efforts ne
suffiront pas accueillir et soigner la
totalité des blessés dont des grands
brûlés qui pourraient être évacués vers
les hôpitaux des armées depuis la fin de
matinée
des unités mobiles ont été installées
tout proche du lieu de l'explosion
mais la plupart des victimes sont
hospitalisés à l'hôpital pur bande dans
le centre de la ville karine comazzi
denis par dano dans ce hall d'entrée de
l'hôpital purpan
l'infirmière vient d'accrocher une liste
celle des blessés admis dans la journée
qu'est ce que vous cherchez pour
accueillir les 348 blessé tout le centre
hospitalier s'est mobilisée dans ce
hangar
on a même improvisé des urgences avancé
je suis aide soignante à la retraite
depuis deux ans et quand j'ai entendu
cette catastrophe je me suis présentée
spontanément à la première équipe du
matin est resté en place dans tout le
monde est mobilisé tout le monde est sur
le pont je dis bien que au plan médical
au plan soignants la situation est
vraiment maîtrisé mais le plus dur est à
venir car après les coupures et les
traumatismes il y à ces chocs invisible
causés par le souffle de l'explosion
il faut tous systématiquement les
examiner
les examiner avec les scanners pour être
sûr que en laisse repartir les gens
totalement dédouané de toute ces lésions
internes graves
et puis il ya cette immense besoin de
parler auxquels répondent les
psychologues
car déjà on se repasse la catastrophe
comme un film tout est possible
tout le monde s'est précipité dehors il
ajouté me beji
ce qui s'est passé hier au terrorisme
tout de suite c'était la première image
que j'ai eu dans ma main je croyais que
c'était dans un attentat vous avez eu
peur de la santé oui mais c'est ce que
j'ai pensé quoi bras n'est pas si vous
ramenez pas content
outre les 18 morts une trentaine de
personnes sont blessées grièvement
quant à ceux qui quittent l'hôpital ce
soir beaucoup vont retrouver des maisons
dévastées
10h21 à trois kilomètres du centre ville
de toulouse
de très fortes explosions séparées de
quelques secondes proviennent de l'usiné
chimique azf classé zone seveso
c'est-à-dire zone dangereuse
le souffle est énorme ressenti d'abord
sur la voie rapide toute proche
les automobilistes sorte hagard parfois
blessés de leur voiture très endommagée
à quelques mètres de là l'usiné qui
fabrique des engrais est évacué
on a eu une explosion on s'est tous
retrouvés dans l'état où on est là je ne
peux pas vous en dire plus pour
l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les blessés et j'ai fait
évacué à l'hôpital marchant qui est à
côté
la plupart des gens valides parce que
nous avons potentiellement un problème
de gaz de fuite de gaz ans dans l'usiné
l'explosion a détruit deux bâtiments
industriels long d'une centaine de
mètres chacun les dégâts sont
considérables dans toulouse même c'est
la panique
gêné par les embouteillages les secours
se rendent sur place sur les trottoirs
on improvise les premiers soins la
population est sous le choc
juste à côté juste en france vous savez
et je me suis retourné j'ai visé pas
votre métier dans le ciel est d'un grand
soufflet selon des témoins 20 30
secondes après l'explosion un nuage
s'est élevée au dessus de lusine une
forte odeur d'ammoniac s'est
immédiatement répondu sur toulouse la
protection civile a demandé aux
habitants de rester confinés chez eux
deux heures après l'accident un premier
bilan a été dressé
il y aurait dix morts 130 blessés dont
30 grave
mais tout d'abord dont cette explosion à
toulouse il était 10 heures 20 ce matin
lorsqu'une déflagration s'est produite
dans une usine pétrochimique de la
périphérie
l'ondé de choc qui a été ressenti sur
4km les toulousains ont d'abord cru à un
attentat mais il s'agirait plus
vraisemblablement d'un accident jennifer
alberte un véritable champ de bataille
partout de la poussière des voitures
éventrée peu avant 10h30 ce matin les
automobilistes qui empruntent la rocade
sud ouest de toulouse se trouve sans le
savoir au coeur d'un bras
[Musique]
laâyoune grande roue regardé soit après
avoir fui ont comme une bombe qui a
explosé là bas c'était la batte pas la
bastille et toute une vie à l'essayer
garder la maîtrise du jeu écrit
autrement c'est un accident si
incroyable d'un coup comme ça à quelques
mètres de là une violente explosion
vient de souffler l' usine pétrochimique
azf défigurée par un cratère de 50
mètres de diamètre et 15 m de profondeur
près de 400 salariés sont immédiatement
évacué
le que je fais on est sorti le plus vite
possible mais bon c'est bon régime en
premier ressort que j'évite ça on a eu
une explosion ont surtout se retrouver
dans les pas où on est là je ne peux pas
vous en dire plus pour l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les blessés et ils sont près
de 650 dont 50 dans un état grave
une vingtaine de morts également et une
vingtaine d'autres personnes portées
disparues un nuage chimiques s'élève
bientôt des décombres de lusine jaunâtre
sentant fortement l'ammoniac
il se dirige vers la ville un périmètre
de sécurité de 30 km est mise en place
et la préfecture demande aux habitants
de rester chez eux
en milieu d'après midi ces mesures sont
levés
le nuage n'est pas toxique mais
l'explosion proviendrait des nitrates
d'ammonium présents dans l'usiné
ils ont explosé
comme ça peu comme ça se fait
habituellement pour ce genre de produit
lorsqu'il est chauffé
reste à expliquer comment ces produits
ont pu être chauffée sabotage attentat
ou accident aucune hypothèse n'est
encore écarté pour le moment nous sommes
avec les policiers et les experts qui
ont été commis en phase de recherche de
rassemblement d'éléments et ont
justement plus on va ratisser large au
niveau du recueil des éléments plus on a
de chance de savoir un certain nombre de
choses le srpj de toulouse a déjà saisi
les bandes de surveillance informatique
de lusine et une enquête en recherche
des causes de la mort est ouverte
a bordeaux revenir à la polémique qui
s'amplifie depuis hier essayant de
comprendre comment l'usiné chimique azf
construite en 1924 loin de la ville a
peu à peu été entouré par des
habitations résultant de l'expansion
naturelle de l'agglomération ceci
explique la localisation de cette
entreprise potentiellement dangereuses
dans un périmètre habité reportage
isabelle de lyon olivier cots blessées
par l'explosion cette toulousaine
rentrer chez elle dans un lotissement
récent à moins d'un kilomètre du jour
ici les habitants se croyait en sécurité
donc tu es content parce qu'on était
dans un côté d'un parc agréable lac des
jeux pour les petits des maternelles à
côté des collèges a coûté on avait tous
les commodités mais on s'attendait pas à
ce à quoi est-ce que vous pensez que
vous payez soyez pas cher parce que
c'est près de l'usiné ça n'a rien à voir
madame le pôle chimique de toulouse il y
a trente cinq ans derrière les cheminées
la verdure aujourd'hui la ville a
rattrapé les usines partout des
immeubles des commerces
quand ils ont poussé à la fin des années
60 on ne donnait pas cher de la chimie à
toulouse il ya eu une série de
restructurations
on ne savait pas quel était l'avenir de
cette usine et ont pensé que
progressivement l'activité déclinerait
trois usines sur le site
elles ont toutes survécu la chimie mme
les toulousains personne n'a eu le
courage de choisir fondement dans
l'isthme de partir son demande aux
habitations de reculer non on a laissé
juxtaposés ça c'est vrai que toulouse
est habitué à vivre avec le risque de
l'onia à force de vivre à l'ombre d'une
bombe on attend plus les tic tac
dans une lettre au préfet en mai dernier
le nouveau maire de toulouse demandé ce
qui se passerait en cas de sinistre
philippe douste blazy insistait pour
éviter tout risque de catastrophe la
prévention n'a pas suffi
accident ou attentats on s'interrogeait
depuis trois jours à toulouse sur les
causes de l'explosion de l'usiné
chimique azf
apparemment la justice en sa possession
de nouvelles informations
un certain nombre d'éléments techniques
nous permettent d'évacuer quasi
totalement la thèse d'un acte de
malveillance a dit tout à l'heure le
procureur sur place
zine dine boudaoud françois-xavier
butant en dépit des apparences le
directeur de l'usiné azf avait ce matin
toutes les raisons d'être inquiet serge
biechelin s'attendait à être interrogé
par les policiers
c'est chose faite les hommes de la
police judiciaire s'intéresse de près
aux conditions dans lesquelles le
nitrate d'ammoniaque étaient stockés il
aurait déjà réuni suffisamment
d'éléments pour privilégier une thèse à
toutes les autres une somme de
négligence serait à l'origine de la
déflagration
nous privilégions à plus de 90% la piste
accidentelle
les constatations techniques et
concrètes qui ont pu être faites sur le
terrain nous permettent de dire que les
chances qu'il s'agisse d'un accident
sont majoritaires et ne laisse que très
peu de place à un acte de malveillance
qui avait pu être envisagé au départ
depuis 20 ans henri farreny dénoncent la
dangerosité du site
ce qu'il redoutait s'est produit
l'ampleur des dégâts accroît encore sa
colère preuve à l'appui
l'ancien élu écologiste dénonce le fait
que l'explosion du nitrate d'ammoniaque
n'aurait jamais été officiellement
envisagée
je pense que l'accident qui s'est passé
il n'est pas classé seveso c'était
nitrate d'ammonium explosion il est pas
là les dames c'est à dire que le sous
dimensionnement du risque était telle
que ça n'a pas été classé comme un
risque majeur alors que c'est ça qui
s'est passé et que ça dépassait les
frontières de l'usiné alors que ce qui
caractérise un risque majeur c'est un
appartement où il ya risque de
dépassement des frontières là ô combien
a dépassé autrement dit la dangerosité
du nitrate d'ammonium aurait
volontairement été minorés une dizaine
de rescapés de la catastrophe est décidé
à poursuivre en justice les responsables
de lusine les dirigeants de total fina
elf
après une semaine sur le terrain de
nombreux bénévoles viennent ici se
changer les idées quelques heures deux
mille places pour un concert gratuit
offert aux toulousains le but récolter
un maximum de dons pour redistribuer aux
plus vite l'argent aux démunis
le premier se mobiliser c'est claude
nougaro chanteur emblématique de la
ville meurtrie par ce qui s'est passé
j'aime bien parfois brillé par mon
absence mais cette fois ci non je ne
pouvais pas ne pas venir il ya le
quartier qui s'appelle d'ailleurs qui
s'appelait en tout cas dans mon enfance
la poudrière qui se mettent à voilà à
sauter dans le dans l'effroi dans la
mort dans les amputés agit
[Musique]
autour du jeu
autour
[Musique]
et vous où une dizaine d'artistes
étaient présents sur scène une trentaine
d'autres avaient envoyé des messages de
soutien pour pouvoir soutenir encore
plus je vous envoie tout là on est en
plein je crois dans le rôle de l'artiste
finalement dans la société quoi qui est
tout en faisant son métier soulager un
peu si c'est possible
le malheur des gens la solidarité des
artistes est allé droit au coeur des
toulousains ça nous a aidé un petit peu
à exorciser un petit peu tout ça moi ce
stress qu'on a chargé sur nos épaules
depuis une semaine
on n'oublie pas que demain ça
recommençait à 6 heures on y retourner
en continu continuent à déblayer à
soigner avec le réconfort de savoir
qu'ils sont soutenus
non
justice les suites de l'enquêté sur
l'explosion de l'usiné azf avec cette
scène étonnante à toulouse ce matin
après les ouvriers le directeur de
l'usiné certains de ses collaborateurs
ont été placés en garde à vue
à leur arrivée à l'hôtel de police ils
ont été applaudis par une cinquantaine
de salariés dont les délégués cgt
reportage in boudaoud alexandre de laval
le directeur de l'usiné azf ne répondra
ni aux questions des journalistes ni à
celle des policiers en garde à vue
depuis ce matin il a choisi le mutisme
pour stratégie applaudi serge biechelin
le soutien de ses salariés créent et qui
forment que on échappe un peu aux
rationnelle et qu'elles se trouvaient
leurs mains dans l'affectif
ça fait partie de la vie c'est une dure
leçon de la vie que nous sommes en train
de vivre huit cadres de l'usiné sont
aussi interrogés par les policiers
plusieurs ingénieurs et le chef de la
sécurité
tous sont soupçonnés de négligence après
48 heures de garde à vue ce
sous-traitant d'azf est libre il a été
loquace muré dans le silence les cadres
de lusine passeront leur première nuit à
l'hôtel de police
le rapport fait 700 pages il mais
théoriquement un point final à la
controverse sur l' usine azf de toulouse
dont l'explosion avait fait 30 morts et
des milliers de blessés
pour les experts il s'agit bien d'un
accident dû à des négligences de
manipulation des conclusions que
conteste toujours la compagnie total et
qui était présenté aux familles
aujourd'hui zine dine boudaoud à la
location oui mais il va persister ce
nous fournit pas la preuve que le club
expertise pour manque d'encre aucune
conclusion nette et claire pour eux la
parole des experts judiciaires n'est pas
parole d'évangile et d'anciens salariés
lésés des là ils ne veulent pas en
démordre l'accident restent encore à
trouver les juges d'instruction se sent
pourtant voulu pédagogue ils ont demandé
aux experts d'expliquer aux cent
quarante parties civiles du dossier les
conclusions de leur rapport final
pendant plus de cinq heures et à huit
clos le film de la catastrophe a été
rejouée convaincant pour beaucoup pour
nous c'est une grande satisfaction de
pouvoir dire on arrête avec la rumeur on
arrête avec des causes exogènes
forcément exogènes si toujours les
trajets se montrer du doigt hassan
jandoubi d'abord la sincérité ensuite
al-qaïda éventuellement tout n'importe
quoi pas un attentat mais un accident
lié à des négligences selon les experts
dans le hangar 221 plus de 360 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium étaient stockés vers
10 heures ce vendredi la 500 kg de
produits supplémentaires sont déversés
dans le lot la justice en est convaincu
quelques kilos de dérivés chlorés du
décès cn à une erreur car la combinaison
des cc n'a plus nitrate d'ammonium est
explosive
plusieurs expériences comme celle ci
semble le prouver
total propriétaire de l'usiné azf ne
croit pas au scénario de la justice
combien d'essais avant de parvenir à
personne n'a trouvé ce qui s'est passé
et c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé
il faut prendre n'importe quoi c'est un
vrai problème et je n'ai pas de solution
pour les proches des victimes la
responsabilité de total dans l'explosion
et prouver qu'ils
réclame donc la mise en examen du groupe
pétrolier
sept ans après les faits enfin le procès
le procès concernant l'explosion de
l'usiné azf à toulouse est ouvert tout à
l'heure on va en parler mais d'abord ces
images pour les plus jeunes ou pour ceux
qui ont oublié
regardez c'était le 21 septembre 2001 à
17h20 quelques minutes après l'explosion
un automobiliste caméraman amateur
filmée l'étendue du désastre
il ne croisait alors que des regards
hagards des blessés par centaines sur le
périphérique toulousain
à ce moment là personne ne savait ce qui
venait de se passer bien c'est cette
vérité justement aujourd'hui que les
familles des victimes et les rescapés
réclame c'est un procès hors normes qui
s'est ouvert tout à l'heure dominique
verdeilhan abdel juillet chez mathias
second assister à cette première journée
d'audience
à toulouse il y a les riverains d'azf un
simple bras ça rappelle qu'ils ont perdu
un proche ont été blessées ou sinistrés
sur la catastrophe du 21 septembre 2001
ils n'ont pas la même vu que les
salariés d'afr
depuis sept ans la justice privilégie la
thèse de l'accident industriel depuis
sept ans
leur association fait de la résistance
on nous raconte une fable depuis depuis
sept ans maintenant qu'ils ont une fable
qui vraisemblement n'aura pas résisté
aux coups qui veulent être portée panale
le procès autres associations autres
parties civiles autre vérité proche
celle ci de l' enquête judiciaire est en
bois dont on connaît les conclusions des
experts depuis le mois de mai 2006 on
sait qu'il s'agit de rational chimiques
shinji chimiques dans la salle
d'audience un seul prévenu face à 1813
plaignants serge biechlin ancien
directeur de l'usiné
mais pour certains c'est le groupe total
qui devrait être jugé moi je tiens à ce
que ce procès désigne le vrai
responsable c'est total c'est la
recherche du profit
c'est ça la raison total qui après sept
ans l'instruction parle d' incertitudes
quant aux causes de l'explosion
pour beaucoup c'est l'incertitude les
normes incertitudes dans laquelle on se
trouve encore aujourd'hui face à tous
les événements qui ont entouré cette
cette explosion en début d'audience le
président du tribunal note lui même
cette cassure entre certaines parties
civiles
alors le procès est filmé pour
l'histoire pour la mémoire pour les
générations futures
mais le tribunal a quatre mois pour
tenter d'apaiser les esprits
autres titres de l'actualité la surprise
au procès de l'explosion de l'usiné azf
de toulouse cet après midi le tribunal a
prononcé une relaxe générale
il se démarque donc des réquisitions
rappelons que la catastrophe avait fait
31 morts c'était il ya huit ans sur
place muriel la saga david bres david da
meda à la surprise générale le président
du tribunal prononce la relaxe pour la
société grande paroisse et % directeur
serge biechelin relaxe au bénéfice du
doute
les victimes de la catastrophe d'azf
sont effondrés écoeuré révolter et
l'allemande ok c'est bon vous avez tous
crever la guérilla le tribunal a donné
la liste de tous les manquements de
prendre part glace et à côté de ça je
pensais que le fait que le jugement il
rit un peu dans notre sens dans notre
défense est là ces manifs
l'anéantissement complet le groupe total
et son ancien pdg thierry desmarest
eux aussi sont relaxés à l'issue de cinq
mois d'un procès hors norme
le tribunal a donc jugé qu'il était
impossible de déterminer la cause exacte
de l'explosion je suis satisfait du
résultat judiciaire
j'éprouve une grosse frustration
personnelle tant que pas simplement
avocat mais mes citoyens simulé de ne
pas avoir réussi malgré tous les moyens
qui étaient les nôtres tous les moyens
gratter sur la justice a trouvé ce qui
s'était passé façon certaine ce qu'ils
vont comprendre ce sont tous les
industriels qui vont se dire on a un
blanc seing d'ores et déjà pour pouvoir
gérer nos usines comme on l'entend
serrer la ceinture sur la sécurité mais
aussi un problème en fait disparaître on
tripatouille on nomme une commission
enquête interne
hénart lallaoui il ya quelque chose d
seulement inquiété le président n'a
pourtant pas manqué d'égrainer tous les
manquements à la sécurité dans l'usiné
grande paroisse mais cette condamnation
morale n'a rien changé sur le plan pénal
très prochainement sans doute le parquet
devrait faire appel de ce jugement
bonsoir dominique verdeilhan vous êtes
en direct sur place vous avez suivi
l'ensemble de ce procès que faut-il
conclure de cette relaxe
à écouter les victimes d'azf ont vécu
exactement ce qu'ont vécu il ya
exactement trois ans presque jour pour
jour les victimes de la catastrophe
aérienne du mont sainte-odile c'est à
dire la douche froide au moment du
jugement
non seulement aucune condamnation mais
surtout aucune explication le rôle de la
justice et d'écrire un scénario de
permettre aux victimes de tourner la
page et ici plus que jamais il y avait
une nécessité de fermer la porte aux
rumeurs aux hypothèses vous en souvenez
l'attentât le météorite la foudre alors
évidemment le tribunal penche plutôt
pour l'accident chimique mais ils en
parlent en termes de probabilités et non
de certitudes faute de preuves
juridiques alors après sept ans de
procédure
cinquante mille pages de dossiers 80
experts un coût financier de plus de 7
millions d'euros ce soir c'est le
constat amer d'une justice impuissante
dominique verdeilhan en direct de
toulouse merci dominique
c'est une décision qui va peut-être un
peu apaisé les familles des victimes de
la catastrophe d'azf le parquet a donc
décidé de faire appel de la relaxe
générale prononcée hier au bénéfice du
doute
ce jugement avait scandalisé les parties
civiles qui savent désormais 1 qu'il y
aura un nouveau procès hélène vergne
david bres en guise de réaction ce matin
une colère froide de tellin dire sur
général je n'ai plus rien à dire un
sentiment partagé par les habitants de
cette rue bernadette particulièrement
touchée par l'explosion d'azf de
l'écoeurement
même si ce matin le procureur a décidé
de faire appel du jugement
au nom de la conviction très forte de
l'existence à l'origine des événements
dramatiques du 21 septembre 2001 de
fautes et négligence caractérisée et
multiples engageant la responsabilité
pénale
selon lui démontrée de la société grande
paroisse et de son directeur
pour le procureur il s'agit même d'un
devoir absolu de vérité à l'égard des
victimes de l'explosion 31 morts des
milliers de blessés
un second procès aura donc lieu rasé en
2001 par la catastrophe l'imprimerie de
michel lasserre était ce matin au lieu
de revendications mais l'annoncé d'un
second procès n'apaisent pas ces
sinistrés car au bout du compte mme
épreuves feront toujours défaut je
trouve qu'on donne un blanc seing pour
pas dire un permis de tuer à des
industriels qui vont pouvoir faire ce
qu'ils voudront repartir là où que je
sois l'épreuve après la catastrophe azf
il valait mardi des cannes à travers un
autre mort on n'a pas tiré les leçons on
n'a pas su quand une catastrophe comme
ça se produit on en déduit pas des
règles pour la sécurité des usines à
quel moment va faire après sept années
d'instruction et des mois de procès
rendez vous est donc pris pour eux tous
dans un an
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]